[Music]
the title of this session is
destabilizing factors and and originally
when we plan this I was thinking about
the dangers due to modernization and the
increased risk of a hi-tech nuclear arms
race and which is certainly
destabilizing and in particular China is
a country that has had a fairly low
low-key response to a nuclear attack and
the rumors are that they're
reconsidering for various reasons
including a modernization program let me
just mention one a few of the buzz words
that have to do a few of the buzz words
that has gone that have been used in
Congress namely maintenance and
modernization so Obama famously said as
long as nuclear weapons exist we're
gonna keep them thank you okay we're
going to keep them ready to go and safe
and so that's maintenance modernization
means that you improve them in some way
for example their accuracy and one
should remember that the lethality of a
weapon is the yield over the era the
aiming error squared so if you improve
the aiming era by 50% you increase the
lethality by double that this is a very
important formula if everyone in the
military pretty much knows this even
intuitively whatever and that means that
conventional weapons which are more and
more accurate are getting more and more
lethal and very rapidly because the
aiming ability of our missiles is
greater and greater
okay so having said that a very rough
preview of what I was going to talk
about let me switch to the issue of
North Korea okay now the first thing I
want to say is that a serious problem is
this too loud is this no this is fine
okay I hear an echo that's why I'm
asking a serious this has been a serious
problem for at least a decade it is not
a crisis when you elevate an issue to
the crisis stage you're implying very
strongly it has to be solved in a very
rapid way that also implies the use of
the military okay what is the most rapid
way you take the facilities out okay
that's quick quick quotation marks of
course it really isn't a realistic
option so you will create a mess for
example the order of the Korean War so
this is the kind of danger that you have
and so making a crisis is
counterproductive if you really want to
solve the problem
that's the message number one now the
New York Times had an interesting
article in the last week or two the u.s.
u.s. president than a dictator in a
snarl off and it occurred to me that
what was not in the article and what is
not in the general discussion is that
the snarl off masks impotence on both
sides and it's the impotence and and
it's very ironic
you have one of the world's poorest and
weakest countries highly militarized but
weak in most respects and they cannot
make the other do what they want
ie coercion they cannot coerce the
others into doing their bidding
ok now the United States wants clearly
wants and should want North Korea not to
be a mill a nuclear weapons power so
that that's a good goal in my view but
you can't coerce them you have to
negotiate with them that's the real
issue so we are not in a position to
force them to give up their nuclear
weapons we have to convince them so in
diplomacy there are the famous carrots
and sticks we have to offer both the
carrots and the sticks ok if you want to
have a successful negotiation ok so as
you know the Korean Peninsula has been a
mess since the early part of the last
century Japan occupied it it was a
brutal occupation World War two ended it
the country was divided the Cold War
came to the Korean Peninsula
the Soviet Union formed North Korea we
formed South Korea within a few years
there was a war North Korea invaded they
thought they would manage to take the
whole country over they almost did but
the u.s. intervened and the UN basically
with US troops rolled the North Koreans
back to the 38th parallel which was the
dividing line and then China
said very publicly do not go further we
went further we went all the way to the
Yellow River China did intervene the war
became a step they threw us back there
was a stalemate so we were at war with
China for a couple of years in the
Korean Peninsula what's usually not
discussed is that in 1953 when
Eisenhower became the president and
there were these failed truce
negotiations going on
Eisenhower famously said these
negotiations are going to end quickly if
they don't we're gonna widen the war and
there was a very strong implication that
nuclear weapons would be used he let it
be known there were consequences to this
mouths a tongue decided that China would
become a nuclear weapons power they
would never be threatened again in this
manner
I'm sure the Kim dynasty with a lot of
emphasis on its own power and survival
as a dynasty almost as much of religious
dynasty as anything I'm sure that was
the origin of their desires for nuclear
weapons so fast forward today they're
there they're there the Korea never had
a peace treaty we have a very weak and
terrible and oppressive government in
the north they really don't care about
their people they've had mass starvation
because of their we
economic policies and the regime's main
goal is to stay in power so we have
really it's it's very tough one should
not envy the president in his role at
having to negotiate out of this thicket
entering the scene because the North
Koreans have been so aggressive in their
screaming we have introduced this THAAD
system this anti-missile defense system
into South Korea
the Chinese hate it for various reasons
I don't have the time to dispute
technically whether the Chinese are
right or wrong I actually think they're
wrong
however they deeply believe that it's a
threat to their missile program okay so
this is a big political issue at the
moment between South Korea China and so
forth we've had a long history this is
why I say we don't envy we don't and can
I get a few more minutes because of the
glitch oh you've done it okay thank you
anyway there been negotiations on and
off I don't want to belabor it because I
don't really running out of time
but what I want to say is that we had
this agreed framework which kept North
Korea from developing nuclear weapons
for approximately a decade the breakdown
of the so-called agreed framework is a
tremendous question of the it's a real
dispute the North says we reneged on all
the goodies that
we said we would provide and our
Congress certainly had a lot to do with
that on the other hand it's true that
dealing with North Korea is pretty
slippery okay so I'm not going to assign
blame but like I said I don't envy the
president
okay so let's fast-forward to the
nuclear weapons and the missiles so so
far north Korea has had five nuclear
weapons tests the first one was half a
kiloton and a tremendous success of the
international monitoring system which
again I don't have time to go into is
that three stations picked up a half
kiloton signal and I have to say they
did it with seismic activity and it's a
very noisy system so this is a very
impressive technical achievement they
pinpointed where the blast came from and
one of the planes over flying the site
picked up some radioactive xena and I
think and figured out what kind of an
explosion it was so this was a technical
tour de force of a very low yield thing
so all of the North Korean tests have
been detected by the International
monitoring organizations this is a
tremendous again I just want to
emphasize this a tremendous technical
success very impressive what we have and
I'm going to come back to this issue of
the two leaders screaming at each other
we Thomas Schelling a brilliant writer
for those of you who know about him and
a Nobel laureate had this theory the
so-called madman theory as far as I know
Schelling's theory had to do with one
man and it was modeled after a Nixon
kissing a use of this I I used the word
reckless leader because mad man implies
a certain degree of insanity and what
shelling really had in mind was
recklessness and an ability to convey
the fact that you the leader is not
quite under the control that you expect
in other words they are not deterred and
will not be deterred you cannot count on
that
that's what shelling meant it didn't
mean that they're irrational I want to
just emphasize that okay so as far as I
know shelling never covered the case
where two leaders are yapping at each
other I would guess that the danger of a
mishap is at least four times not twice
but four times two squared as great and
I'm just guessing Elaine called that
parenthetical so it's better in fatica
it's a lot higher that I get that you
can all okay so this is a consequence of
quote all options being on the table
with a strong implication that the
options will be military not necessarily
nuclear I have to point out that in the
United States the press has done a few
things which are worrisome in general
the press has treated North Korea as a
full
middle opponent they're a very weak
opponent I want to come back to that
second of all they've been treating it
as as if it's a threat to the United
States oh thank you okay
I've got to quit clearly but it is not a
threat to the United States but it is a
threat to the region
north Korea has over a thousand missiles
within easy striking the range of Seoul
the South Korean capital and they can
create a hell of a mess in technical
terms and start another Korean war which
will be an international disaster and so
negotiation is the only way out and
that's what's on this slide so I'll be
in glad to discuss it further but I'm
sorry I'm out of time so I have to stop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]